bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 12 mai
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal tout
de suite on commence avec les titres de
cette édition
aujourd'hui jeudi 12 mai la loi travail
est votée à l'assemblée nationale et des
manifestations ont eu lieu dans
plusieurs villes de france
une mobilisation qui fait suite à
l'annoncé du recours à l'article 49-3
par le gouvernement pour faire passer le
texte
les yvelinois se sont mobilisés nous les
avons suivis et hier à montigny le
bretonneux la municipalité a dévoilé le
futur du projet bergson un pôle culturel
mais aussi des logements devraient voir
le jour à la place de l'ancien collège
avenue joseph kessel
les précisions à suivre dans ce journal
et enfin à plaisir le futur de l'école
maternelle de l'école maternelle marc
laurent inquiète
hier la municipalité rencontrer les
parents d'élèves de l'établissement une
classe pourrait fermer à la rentrée 2016
avant une fermeture définitive de
l'établissement pour septembre 2017 et
je vous disais en titre aujourd'hui
jeudi 12 mai la loi travail est votée à
l'assemblée nationale et des
manifestations ont lieu un peu partout
dans plusieurs villes de france
chômeurs lycéens étudiants mais aussi
syndicats se sont réunis à 14h place
denfert rochereau à paris pour un départ
vers l'assemblée nationale une
mobilisation qui fait suite à l'annoncé
du recours à l'article 49-3 par le
gouvernement pour faire passer le texte
les précisions de william el est patrick
jacques de dixmude
c'est la cinquième journée de grève
contre le projet de loi travail examiné
à l'assemblée nationale ce jeudi 12 mai
convergence des luttes chômeurs
travailleurs et étudiants unis depuis
plus d'un mois pour la même cause
comme l'ensemble des secteurs
aujourd'hui on est attaqué violemment
conçoit cheminots vont travailler dans
d'autres secteurs
et aujourd'hui la combat continuant
travail c'est un peu une occasion de
fédérer un peu tous les mécontentements
qui sont en train de s'exprimer dans
tous les secteurs rochman phares comme
ailleurs et cette manifestation
aujourd'hui la en est l'expression cette
loi est celle d'une toute petite
minorité qui l'imposent contre l'avis de
quasiment tout le monde et que donc ceux
qui sont légitimes aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas ce qu'ils prétendent représenter la
nation comme ils le disent eux mêmes et
ce sont aujourd'hui ceux qui sont dans
la rue surveillant suite aux derniers
débordements le dispositif de sécurité a
été extrêmement renforcer une
mobilisation plus faible pendant les
vacances qui reprend aujourd'hui de
l'ampleur même si les étudiants peinent
à mobiliser en raison des périodes
d'examens utilement c'est plus compliqué
puisque les lycéens ont commencé à
rentrer dans une période de bac
les étudiants en temps partiel donc
effectivement la mobilisation est encore
plus difficile que ces dernières
semaines il a commencé quand même faire
beau ça va aider mais on en espère que
la mobilisation ne va pas trop faiblir
et qu'on doit regarder une pression
constante sur le gouvernement vernement
qui a annoncé busage du 49-3 pour faire
passer le texte en force pour les
manifestants c'est un déni total de
démocratie
il est lui un débat parlementaire qui
devait avoir lieu ou du coup le
gouvernement s'est rendu compte qu'il
n'avait pas la majorité au sein de ce
parlement pour faire voter la loi et
malheureusement et badens ils ont ils
ont choisi de faire un délit démocratie
et d'utiliser ce 49 3 qui passe outre et
bat tous les débats démocratiques et ça
c'est une chose qui fait que l'on se
mobilise encore plus aujourd'hui la
semaine prochaine d'autres journées de
manifestation devrait avoir lieu selon
les syndicats ce ne serait que le début
d'une longue mobilisation et françois
hollande s'est rendu ce matin au mieux
rocher produisent numéro 1 français de
l'impression 3d le président de la
république a défendu le projet de loi
travail selon lui un texte de progrès
assurant que l'article sur les accords
d'entreprise ne remettait pas en cause
les principes fondamentaux du droit du
travail à quelques heures du vote d'une
motion de censure déposée en réaction à
l'utilisation du 49-3 par le
gouvernement ce texte doit être défendue
il doit être regardée comme un texte de
progrès il doit aussi être qu il doit
être aussi conçu pour les salariés comme
pour les chefs d'entreprise moi je ne
veux pas les opposer at il déclaré cyan
et plus proche de nous le projet
personnes à montigny le bretonneux
évolué hier soir les habitants de la
ville ont pu découvrir ce projet de pôle
culturel urbain mixte qui comprend
également des logements lors d'une
réunion publique à la maison de quartier
louis jouvet les détails avec dany
brillant
c'est le projet majeur du mandat de la
municipalité de montigny le bretonneux
l'ancien collège bergson fermé depuis
2007 va être détruit à sa place un pôle
culturel et des logements devraient
sortir de terre pour la rentrée 2020 le
tout pour un budget total de 11 millions
d'euros
c'est le plus gros projet de la ville de
vente signés en tout cas pour ce mandat
là et en plus c'est un projet essentiel
bien sûr pour l'activité artistique de
monter ni mais c'est aussi essentiel
pour la construction de loges banques
le pôle culturel devrait regrouper le
conservatoire de musique l'école de
théâtre et le secteur musique amplifiée
situé sur quatre niveaux
le site bergson fera la part belle à la
culture in intel très probablement un
engouement certain qui va se mettre en
place
lors de sa création et qui fait qu' on
est en mesure également de prévoir un
accueil supplémentaire par rapport à
l'effectif qu'on a actuellement mais on
est très confiants de toute façon sur la
pérennité à accorder à ce type de projet
là ce mercredi soir les élus de la ville
ont présenté ce projet d'envergure lors
d'une réunion publique à la maison de
quartier jouve est situé le long de
l'avenue joseph kessel le futur site
inquiète certains riverains je suis
propriétaire de maison juste en face
donc l'idée c'est quand même de savoir
ce qui ce qui va se passer dans le
quartier ce que ça me de venir et puis
en quoi
en quoi quartier la vie de quartier
maître impactés je viens surtout parce
que je suis inquiète au niveau des
parkings l'avenue joseph kessel est vite
pris d'assaut je me demande vraiment ce
que ça va donner
l'association vélo ce qui était aussi
présente
tracts à la main ils veulent interpeller
les élus et les citoyens
la raison de leur mobilisation aucun
aménagement cyclable n'est encore prévu
la réfection de
la venue qu'est celle où il ya des
travaux d'un montant annoncé de 3
millions d'euros qui sont prévues sans
aménagement cyclable alors que
l'aménagement cyclable est inscrit
depuis 2009 dans le schéma directeur
cyclable dans le plan local de
déplacement la destruction de l'ancien
collège devrait s'étaler sur six mois
les premiers signes des travaux seront
visibles à l'été 2010 est et prenons à
présent la direction de plaisir hier
soir la municipalité rencontrer les
parents d'élèves de l'école maternelle
marc laurent situé en centre ville une
classe pourrait fermer à la rentrée 2016
avant une fermeture définitive de
l'établissement pour septembre 2010 est
une école la maternelle à camille
claudel a déjà été fermé en 2016 les
détails avec mélanie poquet et patrick
jacques de dixmude
ils sont venus chercher des réponses ses
parents d'élèves veulent connaître le
futur de l'école maternelle marc laurent
on l'a su par les membres de parents
d'élèves fcpe puisque les cartes
scolaires ont été annoncés le 11 avril
si ma mémoire est bonne on souhaite
conserver cette classe qui est plus ou
moins programmé à la disparition et
l'école parce que on a une école de
quartier c'est une âme ses 40 ans
d'histoire aussi dans cette école et on
souhaite conserver cette qualité de
scolarisation en cas de fermeture les
élèves seraient dirigées vers deux
autres établissements de la commune
l'école composé de deux classes connaît
des baisses d'effectifs actuellement
comme beaucoup de collectivités on est
en train de justement de regarder une
réorganisation et n'ont pas demandé par
nous mais demandé par l'inspecteur
d'académie puisqu'aujourd'hui vous le
savez aussi ont des restrictions qui
font que ils essayent d'optimiser par
rapport au remplissage de classe et en
dessous d'un certain seuil bien
évidemment ils réfléchissent à des
fermetures de classe parce que au niveau
des enseignants ça pose problème
plaisir possède 28 écoles pour trente
deux mille habitants de la ville dément
les rumeurs d'une destruction de
l'établissement pour construire des
immeubles l'école marc laurent pourrait
fermer ses portes à la rentrée 2010 cet
emploi à présent comment retrouver un
travail après une longue période de
chômage le club fasse de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tente
d'apporter des solutions en partenariat
avec la banque populaire ils ont
organisé conjointement le premier leur
premier job academy le concept ses neuf
salariés qui se porte volontaire pour
devenir parrain ou marraine et coacher
un demandeur d'emploi lancées en
septembre en décembre dernier pardon
c'était l'heure du bilan cet après midi
et il est plutôt positif puisque trois
des neuf demandeur d'emploi ont déjà
retrouvé un job on écoute un de ces
binômes au micro de fanny bourdon est
l'idée c'est de dire aux amis qui ont la
chance d'avoir un emploi
relativement sécurisé c'est peut-être
d'aider ceux qui n'en ont pas pour faire
en sorte de leur faciliter la tâche pour
avoir cet emploi ça permet aussi je
dirais donc de se retrouver dans un
cadre d'entreprise
on n'y est plus depuis un moment de
s'obliger donc à s'habiller pour aller
rencontrer son parent a préparé en fait
son interview et ça j'allais dire ça à
son échange
à écrire en fait la démarche et hier le
quartier de fontaine saint martin de
saint cyr l'école était en fait c'était
la première édition de la journée sans
syrienne organisé par la ville
l'objectif de l'événement proposait des
ateliers de réhabilitation de mobilier
urbain en conviant les habitants du
quartier et de la ville autour de
plusieurs animations
en plus des artistes et des associations
présentes ce sont environ 250 enfants
qui ont participé à cette journée
william elle était sur place regarder
transmettre ce savoir-faire et
savoir-être voilà le fil rouge de la
première journée saint cyrienne organisé
par la ville donc à est artiste c'est
elle qui avait réalisé les fresques
place de la république après les
attentats de charlie hebdo
aujourd'hui elle est à saint cyr l'école
pour rassembler autour de ses oeuvres
moi ça me donne beaucoup de bonheur de
partager et de faire passer un message
de paix et d'humanité on est des humains
et on doit rire ensemble vivre ensemble
c'était le message principal de cette
journée
créer un lien fort entre les habitants
de la ville et du quartier de la
fontaine saint martin un quartier gérés
par le bailleur social opievoy on a
monté cette journée pour dire aux gens
on vous hein pas m'en donner c'est vrai
que ça a été long mais maintenant le
l'opievoy décidé de faire des travaux et
on voulait montrer aux gens que ce
quartier on le prenait véritablement en
compte et qui était pas question de dire
que sous prétexte des logements sociaux
c'était un quartier abandonné
présentation du projet de réorganisation
des espaces extérieurs et de
reconstruction de l'entrée du quartier
mais aujourd'hui ce sont les artistes et
graffeurs qui met la main à la pâte pour
décorer le quartier transformateurs ou
cabines téléphoniques
tout y passe c'est vrai qu'on a choisi
d'avoir des activités qui étaient
éphémères sur la journée et d'autres
activités qui allait être pérenne et on
a invité un collectif d'artistes qui
s'appelle sofia ainsi qu'une une
graphiste graffeuse bouka à venir
embellir va tout simplement du mobilier
urbain très désaffectée quelquefois très
mal 250 enfants ont participé à cette
journée
en plus des services de la ville 25
partenaires ont répondu présents à
l'événement qui aura lieu dans un autre
quartier
l'année prochaine il est temps à présent
de passer à notre entretien nous
recevons ce soir en plateau johan
anglade et garnier conservatrice de la
réserve naturelle de 50 ans living
bonsoir à vous remercie d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors voilà la réserve fête ses 30 ans
mais tout d'abord j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur les missions de la réserve
naturelle parce qu'elles sont multiples
alors l'émission d'une brothers sont
multiples c'est d'abord la protection du
patrimoine naturel
le patrimoine naturel c'est tout à faune
et la flore sauvage alors la réserve
cette année fête ses 30 ans c'était au
mois de mars que vous avez un grand
événement il ya eu beaucoup d'événements
beaucoup de natifs que vous avez mis en
place est ce qu'on peut les rappeler
rapidement
oui alors on met en place plusieurs
événements sur l'année pour fêter les 30
ans date importante fait trente ans donc
depuis 1986 que la réserve sur le
territoire de saint quentin et notamment
l'événement fort de cette année c'est
que nous sommes rapprochés des habitants
de trappes puisque les limites de la
réserve naturelle sont entièrement sur
la commune de trappes et donc nous avons
été à l'honneur sur la semaine du
développement durable qui a eu lieu au
mois d'avril et ses près de 350
trappistes surtout des jeunes qui ont
été sensibilisés qui ont pu visiter la
réserve où on est allé à leur rencontre
pour leur dire ici il ya une réserve à
quoi ça sert qu'est ce qu'on y fait
et surtout venez la voir alors vous
organisé en ce moment une exposition
photos l'objectif c'est de encore faire
connaître l'art et zaoui toujours encore
et toujours parce qu'en fait même ça
fait 30 ans qu'on est sur le territoire
souvent quand on rencontre même un saint
quentinois
c'est rare qu ils sachent seulement
l'existence de la réserve naturelle
donc l'idée c'est de mettre donc des
photos des oiseaux parce que c'est une
réserve ornithologique dans les lieux
publics les plus visités je dirais par
les habitants et une mairie bassa s'y
prêtait donc il ya plusieurs bénévoles
qui se sont associés à cet événement
pour mettre donc des photos d'oiseaux et
faire un travail sur l'observatoire de
la réserve
les photos que l'on voit donc à l'image
alors en trente ans il y avait forcément
des évolutions s'être compliqué de faire
un million mais ce qu'il ya eu des
évolutions écologique
en tout cas au sein de la réserve oui
alors en fait la réserve naturelle c'est
vraiment un effet refuge pour la nature
sauvage surtout que en ile de france
elle se fait rare et donc
eh bien les animaux et les plantes sont
préservés sur ce terrain donc il ya des
plans ce condo des plantes ou des
animaux qu'on voyait qu'on ne voit plus
et puis il y en a d'autres au contraire
qui est viennent se réfugier
donc c'est un bios un bilan plutôt
positif
je dirais le point noir c'est un peu la
pollution qu'ils allaient installer
c'est à cela plus rare qu'on peut voir à
la réserve voit nulle part ailleurs
alors je dirais la plus rare pour
l'espèce végétale c'est le plantes à
feuilles de graminées puisqu'en fait
c'est une redécouverte pour l'île de
france ce serait la seule station se
serait elle serait présente uniquement
sur l'étang de saint quentin
donc là c'est véritablement rares et
pour les oiseaux j'aurais envie de
donner le nom du blongios nain qui est
un petit et rond vous avez une trentaine
de couples en ile de france et quelques
coupes chaque année donc là on les
attend vienne sur l'étang de saint
quentin pour se reproduire
il ya également des naissances à la
réserve à ce qu'il ya eu des
transformations économiques parce que la
réserve aussi à porto territoire oui
alors la réserve naturelle fait vraiment
partie de ce territoire je dirais que de
plus en plus on sent une appropriation
de tous les publics et des partenaires
à l'occasion de
du vernissage de l'exposition de trappes
le maire monsieur le maire donc évoqué
cette réserve comme un trésor
donc voilà je pense que tout est dit les
missions scientifiques également
revenants sont pas importantes voies de
votre avis fin de ce qui se passe dans
la réserve
vous avez déjà travaillé sur certaines
notamment voilà un gros un gros livre
qui a recensé toutes les espèces delà de
la flore les aussi un travail qui se
répare sur la fois non oui en fait c'est
la suite logique c'est de travailler sur
la richesse principale de cette réserve
qui est l'ornithologie donc les oiseaux
sauvages qui viennent ici en migration
en hiver ou en reproduction et donc
c'est le dirait le deuxième volume c'est
de compléter la flore sur les étangs en
amont parce que la saint quentin fait
une chaîne des temps est liée au
patrimoine historique de roi louis xiv
et donc vous avez faut pas oublier la
môme en fête en cette histoire donc on
va élargir en fait le livre sur la flore
de l'ensemble du réseau des étangs et on
va étudier leurs nouveaux logis aussi à
l'échelle de ce réseau des étangs rigole
avons misé au bout de 30 ans certains
saint quentinois ne vous connaissez pas
encore et non qu'est ce qu'il explique
comment vous vous l'expliquer justement
alors j'ai du mal à à donner aux toutes
les explications c'est vrai que pourquoi
peut-être qu'on a on n'a pas su en fait
toucher régulièrement les saint
quentinois tête ils connaissent bien
l'île de loisirs et c'est vrai que la
réserve naturelle si vous rentrez sur
l'île de loisirs elle est à l'intérieur
maintenant il ya une clôture donc vous
pouvez pas y rentrer quand vous le
décidez il faut venir en sur des
activités qui sont programmés je pense
que c'est c'est une des raisons qui fait
qui fait ce constat mais en tout cas la
volonté véritablement c'est de faire
découvrir ce patrimoine parce qu'il est
exceptionnel et ici donc autant que ça
profite aux plus grandes
alors justement est-ce qu'il va y avoir
d'autres événements bientôt justement
pour à ses 30 ans qui vont donner aux
environs les cinq ans à venir
oui alors les uns prochain événement ce
serait
une exposition aussi à
montigny-le-bretonneux cette fois ci
puisque ce sont râpé montini ce sont les
deux communes qui censurent lille donc
c'est les habitants les plus proches je
dirais de cette réserve naturelle
après on en a les activités classiques
que vous pouvez faire chaque année en
fait à la réserve naturelle vous pouvez
la visite et les prochains événements
c'est donc à une randonnée organisée ce
week-end là samedi 21 mai vous avez la
fête de la nature donc ça c'est chaque
année vous pouvez visiter gratuitement
la réserve naturelle
on aime faire du canoë nature aussi fin
août sur l'eau vous pouvez venir voir la
réserve mais sur l'eau ça change un peu
c'est un petit peu plus ludique on va
dire en fait chaque année vous pouvez
visiter la réserve à peu près tous les
mois sur une visite guidée ou venir le
samedi matin alors c'est une trentaine
de dates à l'année vous avez les
informations sur le site internet de
l'île de loisirs vous pouvez venir avec
votre matériel vont rencontrer des
passionnés en ornithologie
si vous n'y connaissez rien vous allez
apprendre et si vous y connaissez vous
allez vous émerveiller comme ceux qui
viennent très régulièrement sur sur la
raison le site voila si vous avez plus
d'informations le site internet de la
réserve s'affiche en bas n'hésitez pas à
y aller merci beaucoup jeune anglais
devait remercier voilà vous avez
vraiment donné envie de venir
en tout cas voilà n'hésitez pas et vous
nous par ailleurs deux cette randonnée
nous allons ajustements et d'y venir
qu'il vous reste du côté de la réserve
puisque ce week-end les équipes
proposent donc une randonnée un petit
peu particulière aux puces des portes
ouvertes les guides organise une grande
randonnée qui cette fois dépasse le
cadre seul de la réserve les curieux
pourront découvrir le patrimoine de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
à travers sa faune sa flore mais aussi
une touche d'histoire mélanie poké nous
donne un avant-goût regarder
journée portes ouvertes samedi à la
réserve naturelle mais pas seulement
pour la première fois le public pourra
faire une randonnée dans toute l'île de
loisirs quand vous venez visiter la
réserve naturelle je dirais vous êtes
dans le coeur de nature de l'île des
loisirs de saint quentin 18 de ces
territoires
c'est un peu trop tôt maintenant qu'on
fait les expertises scientifiques sont
en science de loisirs et la nature
exceptionnelle et bien sûr l'ensemble du
concours est donc là l'idée c'est d'y
faire découvrir ce que vous pensez
connaître en soit 10 km de parcours
autour du bassin de l'île de loisirs
puis de la réserve
il y sera question de flore avec le
cabaret des oiseaux une plante retenant
l'eau de pluie de faune la base
accueillant de nombreuses espèces mais
aussi de 300 ans d'histoire vraiment
élargir la discussion sur le patrimoine
naturel de l'étang de saint quentin qui
est inscrit dans un patrimoine
historique puisqu'en fait il va partir
en réseau des étangs rigole cet étang a
été créée par le roi louis xiv
l'inscription se fait jusqu'à vendredi
une vingtaine de places est prévu pour
découvrir ou redécouvrir l'île de
loisirs qui délivrera certainement un
grand nombre de secrets nous recevons à
présent sur ce plateau notre journaliste
sportif michael me d'euros pour sa
chronique sport du jeu yvon soirée
qu'elle s'en faisait longtemps qu'on
avait pas fait un truc ensemble
affectivement alors j'ai un plaisir de
vous retrouver sur ce match on devait
mrc également telle au thème de votre
chronique d'aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas
venu seul je vois alors aujourd'hui une
fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler à gymnastique et plus
particulièrement du club j'aime
elancourt mort parce c'est une première
historique l'équipe a qualifié cette
année dix sept gymnastes 15 filles et
deux garçons pour les finales du
championnat de france individuel qui se
dérouleront à montbéliard ce week-end
pour nous parler de la compétition nous
recevons sur ce plateau et miroirs la
coach de l'équipe pour ça alors je le
disais c'est une première histoire qu
effectivement en général on se fixe
toujours l'objectif d'avoir un petit peu
plus de dix gymnastes pour cette
échéance des championnats de france
individuels et cette année elles ont
tout rempli les objectifs lors de la
qualification
et du coup bah on emmène tout le
collectif
malheureusement deux petites blessés
qu'on espérait pouvoir emmener donc à mi
court et mai
mais pour le reste c'est une vraie
réussite cette année on est ravi et
comment expliquez vous cette réussite
justement j'ai envie de dire que c'est
le résultat de leur travail et de leur
acharnement toute l'année sur les
entraînements qu'elles font avec nous et
puis bon il ya toujours un petit peu de
réussite mais c'est aussi je pense une
planification qui a bien été menée
histoire d'être prête le jour j a
présenté les mouvements et elle est
réalisée correctement pour obtenir la
qualification alors qu'est ce que ça
représente les finales des championnats
de france individuels pour projet une
nacelle ça représente pour la plupart ça
parce qu'on a pas mal qui vont réaliser
leur premier championnat transindividuel
les plus jeunes
donc c'est un rêve c'est l'apothéose
beaucoup de stress aussi pour les autres
les plus expérimentés c'est un rendez
vous attendu - fantastique parce que
elles l'ont déjà fait quelques fois mais
c'est beaucoup de pression le fait
d'être en individuel on a envie de
montrer qu'on est à son meilleur niveau
peut-être de briguer une médaille mais
la concurrence est telle que c'est à
celle qui raque y réussira le mieux le
jour j c'est le jeu de la concurrence
mais c'est beaucoup de pression pour
elle en général en équipe qui a un petit
peu moins de pression mais là en partant
à 15 h gym féminine et deux masculins je
pense que le collectif à les faire aller
faire faire de belles choses
comment on prépare une compétition comme
celle là j'imagine qu'il ya beaucoup de
pression comme vous le disiez à
l'instant on les prépare
psychologiquement peut-être les
gymnastes avant de partir elle à chaque
fois qu'on se rencontre je vous explique
on prépare à la technique et que bon on
n'en est pas encore au jour j voilà ça y
est on y est la technique elle doit être
affûté depuis un petit moment
donc on répète on répète on répète et
puis beaucoup pour le coup là maintenant
on travaille le mental la confiance en
soi la sérénité la stabilité c'est pas
réussir une fois l'élément c'est le
réussir cinq fois sur cinq essais donc
voilà on leur demande beaucoup de
quantité mais maintenant on demande
vraiment la stabilité pour que arrivé
là-bas la pression qu'elles vont
ressentir justement elles soient
capables de la dépasser et de se
présenter avec en pleine possession de
leurs moyens et il ya des chances de
médailles ce week-end pour le gmail
encore pas là on espère on espère
toujours maintenant peut-être
mais
enfin avancer mais t elle vous voyez non
c'est pour elle c'est pas pour puis
surtout il ya une telle concurrence
arriver à ce niveau-là que dans chaque
catégorie où par exemple elles vont être
elles vont être 30 les 15 meilleurs
peuvent prétendre à une médaille
et puis ça va dépendre de la gymnastique
qu'elles vont proposer des erreurs des
unes des autres
donc voilà mes mails ils vont tout pour
donner le meilleur et une médaille ce
sera formidable et on viendra vous
voulez vous les présenter mais même si
on a des 5e place des quatrièmes places
dès lors qu'elles ont donné leur maximum
et que enfin voilà elles sont à leur
place mais c'est la loi du sport
généralement c'est une compétition qui
vous réussit mais depuis quelques années
on a de la chance
chaque année on arrive à ramener des
médailles elle arrive à ramener des
médailles donc donc c'est super on
espère que on va pas s'arrêter là et
puis que leur travail va être récompensé
et si vous revenez sans médaille ce
serait une déception ou comme vous
disiez on y va surtout pour pour
l'avenir peut-être c'est c'est toujours
pour un entraîneur c'est toujours
extraordinaire de voir leur rêve se
réaliser et de voir le leur travail
récompensé donc une déception si elles
elles sont déçues voilà moi dès lors que
l on était enfin les autres ont été
meilleurs et que l elles ont réussi à
présenter ce qui était prévu sans erreur
et ben et banon sera pas d sion serait
ravi pour elle merci beaucoup et me les
rois et on souhaite bon courage pour ce
week-end est évidemment de ramener plein
de médailles on recevra sûrement sur les
prochaines émissions avec plaisir merci
termine cette chronique par des symboles
américains les templiers d'elancourt ne
devront pas un match pour rester dans
l'élite florane les templiers
d'elancourt qui pointe actuellement à la
dernière place du classement se déplace
sur le terrain des black panthers de
thonon-les-bains une équipe qui les
devance d'une place au classement
ce match est donc cruciale en cas de
défaite les templiers pourront commencer
à préparer la saison prochaine et saint
quentinois pourront compter sur un
effectif au complet avec notamment
l'américain jesse riddick
c'est un match que vous allez sur et
qu'un téléphone je suis vraiment un
mickey je m'intéresse jeu avec assiduité
au sport local et en plus au football
américain il savait voilà je suis fan
dans une série et vous vous savez bien
on n'en dira pas plus on vous retrouve
dans quelques instants pour votre toit
car le talk si on parlait sport alors
les chroniqueurs sont dans l'arène
ils sont prêts à en découdre il y aura
en nous parlerons
mix dans bâle féminin avec la descente
en nationale 2 2 montigny-le-bretonneux
mais également de la défaite
en rugby de plaisir en match de playoffs
de fédérale 3 je vais me dépêcher de
rentrer chez moi pouvoir regarder
l'émission et michael dinner si on
parlait sport à ne pas rater jeu merci
nous avoir suivis et à présent la fin de
cette émission
demain vous me retrouver pour
l'essentiel de l'actu je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée à demain